>> Hello, everyone. My name is Michael. I'm
a 13-year-old boy and I enjoy all things Pokémon,
Lego, Star Wars, and now play video games
and VR all day if you'll let me!
>> My name's Jason, his dad, CEO of a company
called Codeup in the States, and we teach
adults how to code. I know a little bit about
Pokémon, and video games are all right. Before
teaching kids to code and giving you tools
to go back home? And teach kids to code. , let's
talk about why teach kids to code? I think
most people in the audience have some opinions
about that, but I wanted to find out from
a kid. Michael, why do you think kids should
code?
>> Kids need a better understanding of technology.
Most kids think technology is Google, YouTube,
and Fornite. There's a not close to the possibilities.
Coding makes you creative and makes you want
to do amazing stuff, integrate and teach children
logic, like if something happens, do something
else. You also learn how things work. You
can learn how to send an mail, or learn how
a computer works. It's cool to build Lego
and play games. It's cool and awesome to programme
things. It's also really fun. I do on a daily
basis.
>> Awesome. So before we get into the right
way to teach kids how to code, we figured
we would go over a few of the things we think
are the wrong way to do it, and last summer,
Michael was super excited to go to a camp
where they were going to teach Minecraft mods
learning Java and we learned a few things
that are the things to avoid when trying to
teach a code.
>> First thing to start with is a hard language,
Java or C. During that camp, I used Java,
and it was not fun. I don't know how it works
to date. All I know is like C - I don't know.
Make them learn to type. I still use my four
fingers, and using complicated tools like
Eclipse. I have no idea how to go back to
my previous projects. I have no idea how that
even works. Vocabulary, like conkat ...
>> Concatenation?
>> I don't even know what that means. And
they need you to learn maths first - a terrible
way to start.
>> If you want to teach a kid a musical instrument,
you would probably teach him a strong before
you made them learn music theory or read music.
I found as parent once Michael was out creating
video games, all of the things in the slide
he became more interested in. If this is where
we start, then it's really heart to get them
excited about writing code. That being side,
we want to know what kids want to do?
>> This picture definitely shows what I want
to do all day, every day.
>> All day long if I let him. Michael, what
do you think the kids want to do when they
are learning to codes?
>> They want to see results. They don't want
to wait ten seconds -
>> You're telling me kids aren't patient?
>> I've been waiting for you to say that.
And they like to create things that are fun,
like game or Lego. They like to create things
that they are interested in. And sharing that
creation, again back to logo, they love to
show it after they build the set, even I do,
I like to show it to my parents showing what
I'm capable of. To make new graphics, like
doing artwork, or fan art, or anything like
that, they love to do that, and building things
that they love once again, Legos. They love
them, but last but not least, they like to
play with the results. Guess what? Lego. They
love to play with Lego before they put it
on the shelf before letting it dust and rot.
>> Awesome. So, we've talked a little bit
about the wrong way and why kids want to do
it, and what kids are into, so we would like
to present what we think is a great solution
for teaching kids to code, and, in this solution
that we want to show you, do you have to learn
how to type?
>> No, it is drag and drop.
>> Took weeks?
>> No, it was easy learn, and I learned how
make a game in the first day.
>> You're only a few of you online doing that?
>> There is a ginormous humungous community
of users.
>> Why don't you write us a piece of software
that you think you're being punished?
>> Almost fun to use, almost close to video
games.
>> Was anybody able to help you?
>> Yes, it's pretty easy to learn, but if
you do need help, anyone can help.
>> What about downloading games? Did you have
to create special stuff?
>> No, I created one in the first hour without
downloading.
>> What if you want graphics in there?
>> Graphic designs are included.
>> Awesome. We would like to show you the
solution that's worked for us, and that scratch
by MIT, it's super cool! Miming, tell us what
is Scratch?
>> It's a programming language developed by
MIT in 2003, it's for ages eight and up. I
started around seven or eight. Right now,
it has over 22 million users, and roughly
around 25,000 new members join every day.
>> Wow.
>> And guess what? It's in German, it's in
Spanish, it's in Japanese. There are over
70 languages it uses. And it only requires
internet access, and, because of the recent
3.0 update, no Flash! [Applause].
>> Thank you, JavaScript community for saving
us. Awesome. To get Scratch, it's super simple.
You point your browser to scratch.mit.edu,
and you're created with an IDE that looks
like this. In the top-right corner is the
stage.
>> That's where everything is going to happen
where Sprites are going to be moving and changing
president they are the objects on the stage
that, as I said, they're going to change,
move, do something. Those are the backdrops.
Those are the stages of the stage - play on
words there - and it changes, it can write
the code, all that. In the middle, there's
the coding area. That's where you're going
to be putting your code to make either the
Sprites stage change. Next to that are the
blocks. Those are the chunks of code that
we are going to be sticking together and making
your thing work. Above that are the tabs.
Pretty simple code. I just told you what that
was. Costumes is where either Sprites or backdrops
can change, and sounds describes itself.
>> So what we would like to do is a typical
Hello, World using Scratch. Michael will come
over and do live coding for you today in Berlin.
Scratch Cat is the Sprite that is default.
How about you show us a hello world script.
>> First, we go to events and grab the winflag.
You need this for every piece of code we do.
Then we go to looks. Grab a hell. Make that
a simple hello, world. Still using my pointy
fingers. Going over to motion with ten steps.
>> Let's blow it up and hit play. That kid
that you're trying to kitchen to code can
have the hello world script not learning how
to type or having all of those things that
kind of get in the way, so the next what we
would like to do is create a game for you
live, right here, and Michael already went
to the background and used the graphic tools,
created all of us own graphics and what we
see there is Jeff staying at an airport holding
a beer. Tell us the premise of the gale, Michael?
>> So Jeff is German dude, and I'm not going
to do anything weird. He is there, and he's
going to be throwing wiener schnitzel off
bearded dads coming off 48 aeroplanes with
only three hours of sleep, and he's going
to be super angry. He has to throw beers and
schnitzel to make him happy. Angry bearded
glasses dads..
>> Where did you get this idea?
>> With Grey Beard.
>> We want Jeff our main character moving
around. Show us how we can make Jeff move
left when you hit the left arrow button?
>> First, of course, we have to go events
and grab the click block. Again, you're always
going to need this. Go to control and grab
a forever and an if. It's forever going to
be asking the question: if something happens,
then do whatever is in the loop. The thing
we are going to be asking is going to be keyspace
press, but it's not going to be left, it's
going to be left arrow. Go to motion. We are
going to point in the direction left, which
is negative 90. And then move ten steps.
>> All right, so we hit the flag. We hit the
left arrow button.
>> Wait, wait. There's something wrong.
>> Do we have internet?
>> Okay. What's going on here?
>> I'm on the wrong Sprite.
>> Live coding is always fun! Every Sprite
is its own object. We headed in the wrong
piece of code. Now Jeff moves left! All right,
good job! Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
>> So now we've got Jeff moving left but I
think he needs to move right as well. How
do we go in there and make him move right?
>> Easy. You right-click and duplicate, something
amazing about Scratch. You go right arrow
and make that right.
>> Perfect.
>> Zoom.
>> And so we've got moonwalking Jeff.
>> Yes, Michael Jefferson!
>> Let's make him move in the other direction,
pointing in the direction he's supposed to
be moving.
>> Before that, I would like to show you the
costumes. I have a right and a left costume.
These will be important to make it move. We
go back to code. You go to "looks". We go
down here and switch costume to right. Put
that there as well, with this left. It's in
place.
>> So that when he moves left and right, he
will be facing that direction. Jeff can't
move up and down. How hard would it be to
add that?
>> Not very. Just expand, and right-click.
Boom! There we go.
>> Duplicate two more if statements, so four
nested if statements in there checking to
see if it's going up, down, left, or right.
Michael's going to get all of those set up.
We will remove the Switch costume for the
up and down. Accept the directions to down
and up. And when we click Play, we should
have a fully moving Jeff. He moves everywhere,
even diagonal. Check that out. In a few minutes,
you're able to get the basics of a 2D game
going but right now, it's just Jeff running
around on a stage. Let's bring in one of the
aeroplanes and see if we can't get some of
the angry dads to come off.
>> "Aeroplane Michael coming in for landing".
>> All right. Now we have another Sprite,
this is the aeroplane Sprite, its own object.
Michael will start having angry dads coming
off the plane and chase down Jeff trying to
get that beer and schnitzel.
>> Of course, go over to events, when the
flag is clicked. Go to control, do "forever".
Wait one second. And so it's going to wait
one second and then create a clone of myself.
>> That's quick.
>> It's a bit too short.
>> Let's make that a little more random.
>> Let's go to operators, pick random one
to ten. Expand. Make it 2, 2, 6.
>> Every to two six seconds, this Sprite will
create a clone of itself and Michael will
show you what we can do with that clone.
>> When I start the clone, and you're also
going to grab a "repeat until", go to motion,
you're going to point towards a Jeff. And
move ten steps. There you about.
>> So let's see what happens here. And we
wait two to six seconds randomly, and angry
dad!
>> Dad!
>> That's another aeroplane! All right. So
how can we fix that? Instead of aeroplanes
coming out of aeroplanes, we have angry dads.
>> First, I like the costumes. There is plain
and there is Jason.
>> He looks a little familiar. So let's find
a way to get him off the plane.
>> So go back to code. Go to looks. The plane
is not going to be plane.
>> Every time a clone is created, it should
of angry dad. Jeff's going to run around.
Here they come. Angry dads coming off the
aeroplane, chasing down Jeff. I have never
run that fast in my life? You can't convince
me that was based on me.
>> Let's make it six, then.
>> We will make him run a little slower. When
they are catching Jeff, should they not disappear?
>> If you want.
>> Let's show how we could do that?
>> Okay, fine. Go over to sensing and do touching
mouse pointer, change that to touching Jeff.
>> How we have a until loop like a "do while".
Go to ...
>> Go to control again. Delete this clone.
>> So once that loop completes, the clone
will be deleted.
>> Yes. So now let's go back in.
>> All right, so Jeff's out running around
the airport. Every two to six seconds, there
comes angry dads off the plane. When they
click Jeff, they go away. Wouldn't it be great
if we could get them beer and schnitzel before
they caught Jeff?
>> Indeed. Let's go to food and drink. We
have a beer. We have a schnitzel. I like the
beer better than the schnitzel!
>> When we click on this third Sprite now,
we see there's no code there for that object.
We say whenever the game starts.
>> When the flag is clicked, whenever the
game starts, we are going to go to control.
Forever. If also grab while we are here. Then
we go to our sensing. We keep it there. Go
back to control, grab it here.
>> We are creating a clone every time the
space bar key is pressed.
>> Then we go to random position and we go
to Jeff, and then - grabbing so much stuff
while I was here. "Repeat until", and then
we are going to have the motion, move ten
steps. There you go.
>> So now every time he hit the space bar,
a clone should be made of the food object
and it should start moving ten steps from
where it originates.
>> Like CSS you have show and hide for your
Sprites. Now we need to show. Perfect. Awesome.
Wait! But that's like an endless supply of
schnitzel, and they're sticking to the end.
Let's make it where you have to let go of
the space bar in between?
>> I want you -
>> Let's clean that up a little bit.
>> There come the angry Jasons. Shall we fix
first machine-gun?
>> Let's make it where you don't have machine-gun
schnitzel.
>> Okay. So we go over to Control, wait until,
putting on the operators. Grab a "not duplicate
this" so now it's going to repeat saying if
the key space is pressed, make clone but you
can't repeat until the key space pressed is
not being pressed.
>> You've got to let go of the space bar every
time. Let's see how that is working?
>> I'm holding it.
>> Perfect. But they are sticking to the edge
of the screen there. We should probably make
them disappear when they get to the edge of
the stage.
>> So we are making it, we are touching the
edge. We are going to make it where it deletes
the clone.
>> So, when it falls out of the repeat loop,
the while loop, they won't stick to the sides.
That's perfect, but what I what I noticed
is when the angry dads come off the aeroplane,
they keep coming, so we should make that angry
dad disappear as soon as he gets that beer
and schnitzel.
>> Let's go back to plane one. We're going
to operators. Grab an or. Duplicate Jeff.
And boop.
>> So it's going to repeat until it's either
touching the food and drink Sprite or the
Jeff Sprite, and then they should disappear,
and we should have angry dads coming off,
getting ready to get that German beer and
schnitzel, and there it is. Able to feed them
and make them happy. [Applause].
>> But, it's only schnitzel coming out.
>> Yes, the game's a little easy right now.
You can stand in front of the plane and spam
angry dads. What if we had a expected plane?
>> Easy. So you cannot just copy code, you
can also duplicate Sprites.
>> If you notice, when he duplicated the Sprite,
all the code duplicated as well. When you
hit play, we have a video game that is twice
as hard and fast.
>> I forgot something: aeroplane Michael coming
into landing.
>> It's only shooting schnitzels to the left.
>> We need a variable. If you don't know what
they are, you're at the wrong talk!
>> It's going to be our direction variables.
It's variables in Scratch or global. Any Variable
you create can be accessed from another Sprite.
Michael's going to set those variables to
whatever Jeff is pointing left or right.
>> It's either negative 90 or 90. Right or
left.
>> You can see for debugging that the variable
is visible on the stage but you can uncheck
it if you don't want it to be there.
>> Real quick drag a dir.
>> So we are back on the food and drink Sprite.
>> So point direction dir.
>> Choosing that variable, whichever way Jeff
is pointed, that's the way the schnitzels
are coming. I thought we said beer and schnitzels?
>> I can fix that. There you go. Now we go
on to looks. And do switch costume to beer,
and to the beer, we are going to go to the
operators, and switch it to pick random one
to two. If you look in the costumes, it's
numbered one and two, so if I do this, -
>> So now randomly shooting beer and schnitzels.
They want to get that beer from Jeff but he's
able to deliver one for them before they get
to him. We have the basics of a 2D video game
in about 15 minutes, written by a 13-year-old.
This is something you can all go home and
do! [Cheering and applause]. Thank you. If
you give him 30 or 45 minutes, he can build
out a fleshed-out video game. I want now to
show you the final version of angry dad and
Jeff. On the bottom right-hand corner, it
will be the beer mug, the life of Jeff. Let's
watch him play around. So it's the same game
that you saw, except this time when angry
dads come off and they drink Jeff's beer from
him, he starts running out, and so we can
see that when they do catch him, his life
meter goes down -
>> But there is a keg which refills your beer
meter.
>> As long as he is shooting beers at other
people, they stay unhappy. They drink all
of his beer! Game over!
>> It didn't go to End Screen. That's what
we were looking for. Thank you.
>> We would love you to get in touch with
us. You can contact me on Twitter.
>> Thank you all for coming to our talk!
>> Good job.
>> Yes! See you guys later.
>> [Cheering and applause].